[Music]
all right thanks everyone for being here
I only have about 20 minutes and that is
what this session is about in 20 minutes
this one I'm gonna try to do create a
brand new application that has that's a
java-based application with spring and
spring boot that has cre d access to
data store for this particular case I'm
going to add tracing this should be
tracing so you can see who's making the
code to what I'm gonna have correlative
logging so you can see all the log
messages not deploying into a production
environment and got debug your life in
production I'm gonna try to do that in
about 20 minutes how many people think
this can be done nobody oh thanks yeah
like there's some there's some people I
can at this point today all right very
cool so let's do that right now
how many Java developers are here anyone
in this Java yeah that's why you're here
fantastic that's awesome and how many
people here you spring in spring boot
just about everyone all right very cool
so you probably know the drill you go to
start off spring the i/o where you can
go and I generate a new application
actually I'm going to create one with
Kotlin today because we do actually have
a pretty awesome color support on GCP
because it so jvm languages we're going
to use one of the latest version of
spring boot go to package it as a war
file today I'm going to use Java 8 now
here's the important thing when you
actually add the capabilities to your
application what you can do is to add
the different components so here I'm
going to say it's gonna be a web-based
application with the web restful
endpoint we're gonna add this very
important thing kochi CP support this is
basically a project that google has
created in collaboration with pivotal we
add idiomatic integrations we spring a
spring boot and that can actually help
you integrate with many of the google
cloud services including data store
spinner cloud sequel visual api logging
and tracing and everything like that so
that you can code your application
idiomatically
without actually having to use our API
you can use everything through spring so
i'm going to go ahead and generate this
project and see what happens here so I'm
gonna do the Death Zone in the unpack it
now this is the new one so I'm going to
open this up and I don't really have a
backup here today so now I see how this
works out and I have about 20 minutes I
got 17 minutes now and we will see okay
so hopefully you can't see the screen
and this is a brand new application and
I have one class here which is in cotton
and this way the application will go
okay so I'm gonna go like this a little
bit so the first thing I'm going to do
is add data store support so Tina's
stories are no sequel database it's a
document the base you know oriented
database you can use you can use there
is no schema so you can add whatever key
value pairs that you want into the
properties of this and one of the
easiest thing to do is to by adding a
dependency here in spring and we have
spring data support for data store what
that means is that you can actually just
create a POJO
or in this case in Cartland this will be
a data class I'm gonna call it person
something like that person I can't
really spell today oh sorry
demo file already I'm gonna say bar with
IDs I'm gonna have an ID field that's
alone and this can be normal for now I'm
gone through a name which is a string
and can also be no now what I can also
do is to sorry with the currently I need
to use the question mark here okay I'm
going to use Springs and notation here
imma add it as an ID with the ID field
sorry ID right here Capitol ID there you
go and then to map it to a data store
entity I want you to do is to use the
entity annotation here if I can find it
somewhere entity oh sorry
there you go and we're gonna do this in
a second okay so issue actually go ahead
and download my dependencies and build
everything for me with the right
annotations in place so wait for that to
happen and it didn't so what happened
here one second
I think I may have missed one thing here
with the data store stuff let me just
make sure I have this yeah and one for
back here is to just go back to the
console there's a little icon I should
have click which says do you wanna do
you actually want to download the
dependencies and I think I said no so
that's a little problem there so I'm
gonna go ahead and do a plain package
here poof so we're about five minutes in
and that we got 15 minutes to go Oh see
Oh what's going on here oh there we go
I'm resolved entity of course yeah
so I do need to input it into my thing
oh boy what happen here Google store and
hold on let me just do one more thing
here ah sorry yeah
alright so I'm gonna try it something
else but very quickly here I'm gon get
rid of this because what happens here is
that when maven is added that we added
this new dependency I needed to refresh
this project somehow so I think in here
somewhere there is a little maven thing
there we go
I should probably report it so that it
actually goes out and get all my
dependencies downloaded properly in this
case right so let me try this again
hopefully this will come out come out
come out no all right so in that case
I'm just gonna go ahead and find this
somewhere me have to go ahead and find
it so I'm not gonna import or the spring
the spring or the cloud GCP okay that's
their data that screen so we have data
store who the core and I think we should
have an annotation here somewhere that's
actually of the the note of entity which
I'm not seeing for some reason mapping
there we go and who I do remember who
this is okay good all right so now we
have the entity oh map I'm going to go
ahead and create a CRE D service this
can't be called a repository this code
what we call a Dao a data access object
so without we can go ahead and choose
your spring idiomatic way of doing it
and go code is a person repository I'm
going to go ahead and extend the data
store repository interface so we have
something written here Cotillard store
repository and i'm going to give it a
type of the to me and i'm going to the
main object my use and also the type of
the ID which is long and that's pretty
much it
we're going to covertly exposed to this
on to the rest service as well so i'm
going to use an annotation here called
repository rest resource and that's all
it takes
aside from the little digress here with
with with the the the annotation and the
packages but this GPO it takes okay so
now go ahead and compile this hopefully
if everything compiles and ultimately
I'm going to
Grundy's how many people think they
should we just work now I kind of screw
this up a little bit yeah that's right
so we'll see so I'm gonna go ahead and
run this from here so I'm gonna do a
skip test because that's what I do I
don't like to run tests we're gonna do a
spring boot and run and what they should
be able to do is to run this application
on port 8080 and actually have an
endpoint called purses and that will
then be able to allow me to read what's
in datastore and allow me to do a post
into the dashboard and store my data
okay so everything is up and running
about four and a half seconds right here
which is not too bad I'm gonna try
something really cool here I'm going to
use my IntelliJ IDE I'm going to try
this thing called new HTTP request some
of us say test requests and this is
really cool so what I can do is to do
let me see here GTR P so it you can
actually write out your URL here in the
IDE will not say persons I'm gonna see
what's actually there I'm going to go
ahead and run this and we should be able
to see the get method here and we
actually do have some return values okay
thank you thank you that's just the
first part of it but but but there's
nothing here there's nothing here
alright there's nothing here why because
it's nothing in my data store so to put
something in here I'm going to appear on
let me see here post with Jason right
here okay so about do 8080 I'm going to
post it to my persons and point I'm
assuming a little bit here and I'm going
to post maybe my name here someone I say
name is right poof a lot of pressure in
20 minutes there's no room for like
fixing things and okay I think I think
that'd work
so over here you can see that well I did
the post not only that I got a URL that
actually pointed me to the data store
location that's the data store ID that's
auto-generated I just to show you this
is actually real
I do have to go to my dashboard here to
my data store and we should be able to
see this new entry that I just created
so if I go down to the kinds we have the
person kind and we should have the
entity here serene and we go to the
empty and that is a new data entry that
I just created and I should be able to
also go back to my IDE and just show you
what the person is
now returns now rather having no records
now I have one record in here right
pretty cool so we got Siri the axis we
can do the least you can do updates you
can do all of these things now of course
in a typical micro-services environment
that is not enough you probably end up
using the the data store for something
else so for that matter I'm going to
cheat here a little bit with a little
shortcut I'm going to create a hello or
controller that is the rest controller
in Springs terms I am going to have a
mapping here with a slash hello at the
endpoint I'm going to be able to say
hello with the name as a request
parameter and for this what I'm going to
do is to actually reuse my repository so
I'm gonna say private Val person report
streamed on injected into my controller
and when somebody says hello I'm going
to use the repository to also save this
record so I'm going to say safe person
name is the name and something like that
now of course that is probably not
enough you probably want to make a call
to another service I don't have time to
write another service for that matter
however I can simulate one for that
matter what I'm going to say is I'm
gonna say hello to everyone I'm gonna
say hello to a few people myself mainly
one of the first person I work with join
Google Cloud and trishia who was one of
the engineers who work on this project
called sprinkle GCP and I see Moodle in
the audience over there I'm gonna say
hello to Ludo as well and what this will
do is to basically make a risk URL Resco
to the hello endpoint going through all
of these names and say hello to each
person okay and you wanted for me to do
this I do need to have in spring storm a
rest template so I do need to have a
little being here that allows me to make
this request a lot easier and go to go
ahead and use the interaction here I'm
gonna say private Val rest template so
that's automatically injected into my
controller and finally I'm going to say
hello to everyone who so let's give it a
try I'm going to go ahead and go back to
my terminal who is my terminal right
here but stop this we're on this and do
a skip test maybe do a package and
spring boots wrong okay so now I just
went from a CREB service to another
service where I can say hello to it's
going to save the data and also
something else that's gonna say hello to
three four different
people all right so let's see how this
works out so everything started for this
one I think I'm gonna go to my console
instead some got do this
right there because I like this view a
little better so I'm gonna go ahead and
say Claro localhost:8080
hello and the aim is I think come on we
think the audience I'm gonna say hello
to tomorrow who's from we've yeah and
there we go so I can't say hello to
smile and there we go we can also see
though the info log message here so now
let me try to do that all let me say
rather than doing the curl localhost
with the hello let me just do you Oh
like that and I should be able to say
hello to four people now right and every
time I say hello remember is saving into
my data store so for that matter if I
come back here and do a little refresh
this is real that I'm not like none of
this is fake now this is premade alright
so then what do we do if you're making a
code one on the micro service in this
kind of architecture obvious ability is
very important when I means is that you
should be able to see one code to
another via HTTP or messaging or
whatever you should be able to see how
the messages are flowing to do that we
have a really really easy way in spring
and especially with our integration we
can actually use start of a trace and
all we need to do is by adding this one
dependency we will automatically hook
into your application and we know where
the request came in we know what headers
Republic eight and now we can have trace
public gated to start River
automatically for the more what I'm also
going to do is to by adding a logging
dependency here so that all of the log
messages can actually go directly into
statuary logging and something happens
after that really really cool now
because this is a demo so you know
typically you don't actually you don't
actually holy cow a simple every single
request you don't really trace every
single request but because this is a
demo home we need to do is to actually
trace everything so for that matter I'm
going to up the probability of a trace
to about 100 percent so here we go I'm
going to say probability of a trace is
four hundred percent not trace one
person of the request now finally the
last thing I need to do is to configure
my logger
to do that means spring is they use lot
by by default so I'm going to create a
new log back configuration and what I
can do here is to of course add a lot of
back configuration I do have one here
for API in console so what this one does
is that it's going to log to the console
so I can see it on my local machine but
I'm also also going to send the same log
messages to start or logging as well let
me go ahead and clear this in restart
and run now we're about 15 minutes in we
will see how this works out okay so I'm
skipping ties best practices ever for a
demo and we'll see okay so let's see oh
yeah there's a little arrow but that's
okay that's kind of expected that's the
expected error exception we're gonna fix
that here you know in the future
releases of this but we should be able
to see a DAT I'm gonna say hello name is
Deb zone that's where we are right now
and I'm gonna say hello to everyone as
well so I'm going to say hello Perl
localhost 8080 slash now one thing that
you may have noticed is that in the log
messages not only do we see the log the
message itself
we also see are these weird IDs these
are trace IDs actually the first part of
it is the the trace ID in the second
part of this this ping ID and these IDs
are automatically captured by our traced
order and propagate it to the log
messages what that also means is that if
I go back to my to my trace console for
starboard trace I should be able to see
that particular request I just came
through and I can probably see here okay
so I can see I said hello to all I can
see that I say hello to raymandy and
tisha and lo but here's the best part if
you click on the link of show log you
can see all the log messages correlated
to each of the span each of the trace
this is super super useful when you're
trying to debug and figure out what
happened to your application in a
production environment now with the last
four minutes I'm going to go ahead and
pour this into App Engine if you don't
know App Engine to see
platform-as-a-service in my mind is the
original server list because you can
scale all the application to however
many instances you need you'll also
scale back in to zero
well you don't have any more requests so
we have this tool called the cow code
used to be go GCP or tools but this is a
plugin you can add to your IDE I'm going
to go ahead and add app engine support
here and what this will do is to add a
little configuration file for me
so I can go ahead and deploy my app okay
all right so he added this thing called
the App Engine wata XML
now of course with the newer version of
the App Engine we can run java 11 as
well as the jar file but just because of
the demo I'm gonna go ahead and up the
instant size and go to do a menu of
scaling just so I know I definitely have
one instance running somewhere and I'm
going to use the IDE to actually do the
deploy okay so let me see if I can get
to ID here all right so from the tool I
can go ahead and configure my App Engine
deployment as well so I'm gonna go ahead
and add in my configuration now this all
within the IDE is all within the cloud
code IDE I'm going to go ahead and
appoint my app into my awesomely named a
project called white coyote okay and um
I can give it a virtual name I'm going
to call it the version of that zone
maybe I promoted promoted maybe not
that's not promoted for now some kind of
coherent do this I'm going to click run
and this will actually deploy my
application or package stopped uploading
only the file size stream changed into
App Engine and we'll go to provision the
computing instances for you behind the
scenes the computing instances of this
app and we're also going to give you an
HTTP endpoint and it just be ready to go
and ready to be used and over here you
can see that we also have the URL so
this is a dead zone that wise Cody
whatever
Absalom and then download down here is
the D for you are L okay so oh I see I I
think I did make a mistake here I do
need to use the be for instance rather
than F for someone gonna go ahead and
change that into the room in the game
all right
so it's gonna go through this motion
again it's gonna upload the whatever
files I changed and go ahead and
provision in this environment for me
right this may take a little time you
know probably about 20 minutes or so now
I'm skinny now it should probably take
like a minute max but we will see what
happened but
look because I already uploaded the
files in the previous failed appointment
the second appointment actually knows I
didn't change any files so you uploaded
zero files for me right it's really
really intelligent and smart like that
okay so now my application is up and
running I should be able to go ahead and
see it oh my goodness
I have like one minute left and now it's
waiting for the application to put up
and eventually eventually we can
actually see it right so this is
actually running in a production
environment I can see the person's end
point I can see everything that I just
created and this is running in App
Engine in prod now here's the last thing
I want to show you let's assume
something bad happened it happens to me
all the time when I'm live coding we can
actually debug this application life we
can actually go to stat rapid debugger
and we should be able to find my
application here which is the devs own
version of it
I can actually attach my application my
source code into this application now
upload it and then have you ever
wondered like hey what did that user
enter what was the input string or
whatever right if you want to find out
with the proper permissions and stuff
you can so what we can add is what we
call a snapshot point so I can add a
little snapshot point here this is not a
break point it would not stop the world
it would just capture the state of the
application as the code flows through it
okay so to show you this laughing I'm
gonna go ahead and do this it do it this
way one second oh so I'm gonna go to my
dev zone I'm gonna say hello to someone
anyone I don't know I'm gonna say hello
to Gloria for example
now watch the application on the right
did you see it was it too fast as soon
as the application went through that
line of code we captured this state if
we go into it we can see all the
variables that was in context of that
particular call I can also see all of
the co stack and this is a very very
easy way to troubleshoot now lastly if
you ever forgot a lock message this is
what you do you go to lock point and you
can just do but we what I'd like to code
binary
why would lock messages because this is
what people do you say first of all I'm
starting from here and then you say well
if everything worked as you in here and
if doesn't get there you put something
in the middle that's why it's got binary
debugging so like 11.5 maybe something
went wrong now every single time that
the application goes to these lines of
code this block my surgeries will also
be added to your log automatically
without you having to read the point
okay so that's all the time I got and if
you want to see more of this you can
join my session a full 50-minute session
and all of these things and more
tomorrow at 2:00 p.m. all right so thank
you so much for being here
[Music]